Right up there with those fundamental operations is this Adjacent Transform. Let's play a game, folks. What's the name in the Q language for Adjacent Transform in C++ and MapAdjacent in Haskell? It's five letters and starts with the letter P. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 145, recorded on June 21st, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we record live from the roads of Italy during the Slovenia 2023 road trip on the way to Venice. In today's episode, we chat about how to parallelize the algorithm stood unique. Now we can switch to, because we didn't talk about this on the pod.
相邻变换（Adjacent Transform）也是这些基本操作之一。各位，我们来玩个游戏。在 Q 语言中，C++ 的 Adjacent Transform 和 Haskell 的 MapAdjacent 叫什么名字？它有五个字母，以字母 P 开头。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 145 期，录制于 2023 年 6 月 21 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联席主持布赖斯（Bryce）在 2023 年斯洛文尼亚自驾游途中、前往威尼斯的意大利公路上为您进行现场录制。在今天的节目中，我们来聊聊如何并行化 `std::unique` 算法。现在我们可以切换到这个话题了，因为我们在之前的播客里没聊过这个。
What was it? A couple of days ago when we were chatting in the car and we were talking about some algorithm stuff and I asked Bryce. And so now I'll put it to the listener. If you're washing dishes, if you're on a run, if you're on a walk, or if you're just sitting on the couch or sitting in a chair in the backyard enjoying the sunshine, think about this. stood unique algorithm which is an algorithm for removing duplicate values that are next to each other and this is similar to an algorithm called deduplicate or distinct that we chatted about a little bit but the difference is is that one removes all duplicates so the easiest way to do this if you don't care about performance or order, is, you know, in Python, you can just take your list of values and then convert it into a set.
是什么时候来着？几天前我们在车里聊天，谈到了一些算法相关的内容，我问了布赖斯。现在我把这个问题抛给听众朋友们。如果你正在洗碗，如果你正在跑步，如果你正在散步，或者如果你正坐在沙发上、坐在后院的椅子上享受阳光，好好想想这个问题：`std::unique` 算法，这是一个用于移除相邻重复值的算法，这有点像我们之前稍微聊过的一个叫作 deduplicate（去重）或 distinct（求异）的算法，但不同之处在于，它只移除所有重复项中的连续重复项。因此，如果你不在乎性能或顺序，最简单的方法是——你知道的，在 Python 中，你只需获取你的值列表，然后把它转换成一个集合（set）。
And that's a property of a set, is that there's no duplicate values. So, std unique, similar to deduplicate, but you're only getting rid of adjacent values. So the question is, we were talking about the parallel implementation of this in thrust, but you can sort of think of this, you can sort of think of this sequentially as well. And the, the question is what algorithms, two algorithms are used to implement unique. There are two other standard algorithms and we'll, we'll let you think for a sec while Bryce adds some commentary because he already knows the answer. Don't really remember. I do remember talking through this.
集合的一个属性就是没有重复值。所以，`std::unique` 类似于 deduplicate，但你只剔除相邻的值。所以问题是，我们之前在讨论 Thrust 中这个算法的并行实现，但你也可以从顺序执行的角度来思考这个问题。问题在于，实现 `std::unique` 用到了哪些算法？具体是另外两个标准算法。我们先让你思考一秒钟，同时布赖斯会发表一些评论，因为他已经知道答案了。其实我记不太清了。我确实记得我们讨论过这个。
I think I said... Ah, no, it's not remove if. It's not remove if. Ah, right. Okay, one of them is probably copy if. Copy if is correct. Yes, that's the second thing. And then how do you figure out which things you're removing?
我想我当时说的是…… 啊，不对，不是 `remove_if`。不是 `remove_if`。啊，对了，好的。其中一个可能叫 `copy_if`。`copy_if` 是对的。是的，这是第二个。那么，你如何确定哪些东西是要被移除的呢？
Adjacent transform or is it just adjacent difference? In Thrust, it is adjacent difference. And if you actually look at the implementation on GitHub, it actually doesn't explicitly mention adjacent difference. You see something called, I believe it's called head flags. And that is a specialization of adjacent difference where you are using the not equal to, or is it equal to? So it's got, just to clarify, in this implementation in Thrust,
是相邻变换（Adjacent transform），还是仅仅相邻差分（Adjacent difference）？在 Thrust 中，它是 `adjacent_difference`。如果你实际查看 GitHub 上的实现，你会发现它其实并没有显式提到 `adjacent_difference`。你会看到一个叫作——我相信它是叫作 `head_flags`（头部标志）的东西。那是 `adjacent_difference` 的一种特化，你在其中使用了“不等于”——或者说是“等于”？所以，为了澄清一下，在 Thrust 的这个实现中，
it has ON temporary storage to store the flags that indicate whether or not you're removing a particular element? Yes, that is correct. And sorry, and just to clarify, it's, uh, head, head flags and tail flags are two specializations that just sort of shift where the, the Booleans, the trues and falses go, either sort of, does it go with the first adjacent element or with the second adjacent element? So that's why they're called head and tail flags and the flags to indicate where they're the same basically so you want to do it adjacent difference with equal to no not equal to so i was right actually initially because whenever you have a different
它使用了一块临时存储空间来存放那些指示你是否要移除某个特定元素的标志？是的，完全正确。抱歉，顺便澄清一下，`head_flags` 和 `tail_flags` 是两种特化，它们只是稍微调整了布尔值（即 true 和 false）的位置，看它们是跟第一个相邻元素对齐，还是跟第二个相邻元素对齐。这就是为什么它们被称为头部和尾部标志（head and tail flags），这些标志基本上用来指示它们在哪些地方是相同的，所以你要对它们做 `adjacent_difference` 加上“等于”——不，是“不等于”！所以其实我最初是对的，因为每当遇到不同的
value that's when you want to perform a copy but whenever they're equal to each other, you want to ignore them. Um, so I will again ask the typical question that I, uh, that I, I almost always feel like I ask whenever you ask me, whenever we, we, we talk about how an algorithm is implemented, why can't we do this one pass? Um, and I do admit it's a little bit trickier to do it one pass um because doing it like you could imagine doing it a single pass with some sort of like adjacent view um but the problem is that it's you don't just need to see like those two elements like if there's a run of elements let's say that you got like i elements, all of which have the same value, when you parallelize that and split it up into multiple different chunks,
值时，才是你想执行拷贝的时候；而每当它们彼此相等时，你才想忽略它们。嗯，那我又要问那个经典的问题了——每当你们讨论某个算法是如何实现的、每当我说到这个时，我几乎总是觉得自己都会问这个问题：为什么我们不能通过一次遍历（one pass）来完成这个？嗯，我确实承认，要用一次遍历来完成它确实要棘手一些，因为如果你想象一下用某种类似相邻视图（adjacent view）的方式来单次遍历……但问题在于，你不仅仅需要查看那两个元素——假设有一串元素，比方说你有一连串元素，它们的值全都一样，当你把它并行化并拆分成多个不同的块时，
it's possible that one thread could have the start of that run of equal elements, and another thread could have the end of that run of equal elements. Another thread could have the end of that run of equal elements. And so it's not simply sufficient to just look at the two elements next to each other. You sort of need some information propagated from neighboring chunks. But I still wonder whether there's a way to do this in a single pass. What are your thoughts? So we should be clear here. We're talking about in parallel.
一个线程可能会包含这一串相等元素的开头，而另一个线程可能会包含这一串相等元素的结尾。另一个线程可能会包含那一串相等元素的结尾。因此，仅仅查看彼此相邻的两个元素是不够的。你需要某种从相邻数据块传播过来的信息。但我仍然在想，有没有什么方法可以通过单次遍历来做到这一点？你们怎么看？所以我们在这里得把话说清楚。我们讨论的是并行情况。
Sequentially, it is very easy to do this in a left-to-right single pass fashion where you basically just look at two elements at a time, and whenever they're not equal to each other you just perform a copy um and you can also do it uh in place definitely sequentially in parallel though i don't really see how you can do it i think it you it's necessary to materialize that that uh head flags because... I'm not so convinced that it necessarily is. This may just be another example of where you need a reduction that guarantees ordering,
在顺序执行（sequentially）的情况下，要以从左到右的单次遍历方式来做是非常容易的：你基本上每次只看两个元素，每当它们不相等时，你就执行一次拷贝；而且你完全可以原地（in place）进行——这在顺序执行时绝对行得通。不过在并行情况下，我真的看不出怎么能做到这一点。我认为把那个 `head_flags` 实例化（ materialize）是必须的，因为……我倒没那么确信它一定是必须的。这可能只是又一个需要“保证顺序的归约（reduction）”的例子，
a parallel reduction that guarantees ordering, which we've talked about extensively before on this podcast. I mean, you could probably do it, but you're going to end up with a different implementation in that. If you're chunking things up and doing a unique on each one of the chunks, you would then need to basically do an extra,
也就是保证顺序的并行归约，我们以前在这个播客里深入讨论过这一点。我的意思是，你大概可以做到这一点，但你最终会得到一种不同的实现方式。如果你把数据分成很多块（chunk），并在每个块上执行 `unique`，那么你基本上就需要去执行一个额外的……
so it would kind of be like the scan behavior. Not in that you need to keep state. You wouldn't need to, but you would perform uh unique on each chunk and then merge that back together but then still have to perform uh unique on that merged chunks result because if you split a chunk in the midst of a contiguous sequence of equal elements you're going to end up with two elements in a row, basically. And so you need to remove those. So, I mean, I'm not sure if that, I don't think. I'm actually, I'm looking at the, in Thrust, the Cub special.
所以它有点像 scan（扫描）的行为。但不是说你需要保留状态。你其实不需要，但你会在每个块上执行 `unique`，然后把它们合并起来，接着你还得对那个合并后块的结果再次执行 `unique`。因为如果你在一连串连续相等的元素中间把一个块切开，你最终基本上会在交界处得到两个连续相等的元素。所以你需要把它们移除。所以，我的意思是，我不太确定这是否可行，我不认为……实际上，我正在看 Thrust 里的 Cub 特化版本。
Oh, no, no, no. Okay, I'm looking at, yeah. Hmm. You got a listener who has no idea what you're talking about. I was looking at the Cub. I was looking at how we implement this in, I was looking at the, how we implement this in thrust. And, uh, no, Connor is correct. We do seem to do it in two passes right now, which is, I think, unfortunate.
哦，不，不，不。好吧，我在看，对。嗯。听众朋友们可能会觉得你们俩完全不知所云。我刚才在看 Cub。我当时在看我们在……中是如何实现这一点的。我当时在看我们在 Thrust 中是如何实现这一点的。而且，嗯，康纳是对的。我们现在似乎确实用了两次遍历（two passes），我认为这挺遗憾的。
Listen, folks, we're headed past a speed camera. I'm happy to report we're not speeding. You know why? That's because the speed limit's 130, baby! Woo-hoo-hoo! We love it. We're going 126. We should, we should clarify this isn't
听好了各位，我们正开过一个测速摄像头。我很高兴地向大家汇报，我们没有超速。你知道为什么吗？因为限速是 130，宝贝！呜呼！太棒了。我们正以 126 的速度开着。我们应该——我们应该澄清一下，
kilometers per hour, not miles per hour for our American audience. Yep. That's the only time, basically, we're under the speed limit is when the speed limit is 130. Or when we're in a kid's school zone, because we've got to protect the children.
对我们的美国听众来说，这里说的是公里每小时，而不是英里每小时。没错。基本上，我们唯一低于限速的时候，就是限速高达 130 的时候。或者当我们开进儿童学校区域的时候，因为我们得保护儿童。
Yes, yes, of course. What is that reduction that we've talked about before? Is it a... It's an associative-only reduce. Yes. So a reduce that supports non-commutative operations. Correct.
是的，是的，当然。我们之前讨论过的那个归约是什么来着？它是……它是一个“仅具结合律的归约（associative-only reduce）”。是的。也就是说，支持非交换操作（non-commutative operations）的归约。没。错。
So this non-commutative reduce, could you do it with that? No, this has nothing to do with reductions, right? You can do it with that no this has nothing to do with reductions right like um you can do it in your quote-unquote single pass thing and i think really more you're right it's not it's not it's not really a reduction i need per se more it's it's uh it's not about really doing this in a single pass what we're trying to do is not materialize this uh flags that looks at yes yes temporary storage so i think i think we should clear it clean up our be a little bit more precise about what we're talking about here and you can do that with that strategy of like chunking
那么这个非交换归约，你能用它来做这事吗？不，这跟归约没有任何关系，对吧？你可以用你的所谓“单次遍历”的方法来做这事——而且我觉得更准确地说，你是对的，它其实、其实、其实并不是一个归约，不需要归约本身；更多的是……这其实并不是关于在单次遍历中完成这件事，我们试图做的是不去实体化那个用来进行观察的 `flags`——是的，是的，临时存储。所以我想、我想我们应该把话说清楚，对我们在这里讨论的内容表达得更精确一点。你可以用那种分块（chunking）的策略来做到这一点，
and basically doing uh you uniques on each of your chunks but then like i said when you merge those back together you're going to end up still having to do another unique to get rid of the potential duplicate values that are at the edges of the chunks, which, like I said, I'm not sure if that's going to end up being more performing because you're basically doing things... I mean, I don't know. A lot of algorithms still do a lot of extra work.
基本上在你的每个块上执行 `unique`，但正如我所说，当你把它们合并回来时，你最终仍然需要执行另一次 `unique`，以摆脱那些可能存在于块边缘的潜在重复值。正如我所说，我不确定这最终是否会更有性能优势，因为你基本上在做很多……我的意思是，我不知道。很多算法仍然在做很多额外的工作。
I wonder if you can do it in a single pass with a scan. I mean, even if you did do it with a scan, that's, and I know you could, because you're getting rid of stuff, right? Yeah, yeah, the problem is you need, the scan doesn't give you the ability to eliminate stuff. You need something that can, hmm. And the thing is, too, is if you... This game doesn't give you the ability to eliminate stuff. You need something that can... And the thing is, too, is if you're doing unique on each one of the chunks, you're doing basically like a bunch of copy-ifs,
我在想，你能不能通过一次 scan（扫描）在单次遍历中完成它？我的意思是，哪怕你真的是用 scan 来做的，那——而且我知道你可以，因为你要把一些东西剔除掉，对吧？对，对，问题在于，scan 并不能赋予你消除元素的能力。你需要某种能够……嗯。问题还在于，如果你……scan 并不能赋予你消除元素的能力。你需要某种能够……而且问题还在于，如果你在每个块上执行 `unique`，你基本上就是在执行一堆 `copy_if`，
which is going to be super expensive. You're doing copy-ifs on each of the chunks, and then you're doing a copy-if for the final stood unique. I just think probably the implementation that is there right now is the best one. I'm not convinced. Here's the follow-up though is that uh the reason i kind of brought this up was that i love i love listen folks let me tell you what i love i love the fact that there are all these different specializations of adjacent uh difference and now adjacent transform i think it's really like the fact that adjacent difference and now adjacent transform. I think it's really like the fact that adjacent
这会非常昂贵。你在每个块上都在做 `copy_if`，然后还要为最终的 `std::unique` 做一次 `copy_if`。我只是觉得，现在现有的那个实现可能就是最好的。对此我不太确信。不过接下来的问题是，我之所以会提起这个，是因为我喜欢——我喜欢，听着各位，让我告诉你们我喜欢什么：我喜欢这样一个事实，即 `adjacent_difference`（相邻差分）有这么多不同的特化版本，现在又有了相邻变换（adjacent transform）。我觉得这真的很像——事实上，相邻
difference has such a bad name is really, it's really, really unfortunate because it is such, I think, an important algorithm. It's only an adjacent difference really is an adjacent transform, but this zip tail type of transform, what's called map adjacent and Haskell and zip with next, I think in in kotlin there's a bunch of different languages that call this different stuff it's such an important pattern and deserves like i think it deserves to be up there with you know we've got reduces and folds we've got scans we've got maps we've got filters right up there with those fundamental operations is this adjacent transform so much so that in the language queue that we talked about several episodes ago when we were solving that skyline problem, Q has an adjacent difference function called, do you know what it's called, Bryce?
差分（adjacent difference）有一个这么糟糕的名字，真的是、真的是非常非常遗憾，因为它是一个非常、非常重要的算法。相邻差分其实本质上就是一个相邻变换（adjacent transform），但这种 zip-tail 类型的变换——在 Haskell 中被称为 map adjacent，在 Kotlin 中被称为 zip with next，还有好几个不同的语言把这叫作各种不同的东西——是一个如此重要的模式，它理应——我认为它理应与我们拥有的 reduce 和 fold、scan、map、filter 一起，跻身那些基本操作之列。这相邻变换（adjacent transform）就和那些基本操作平起平坐，以至于在我们几集之前为了解决天际线问题而讨论过的 Q 语言中，Q 语言有一个名为——你知道它叫什么吗，布赖斯？
I do not. Five letters and starts with a P. Let's play a game, folks. What's the name in the Q language for adjacent transform in C++ and map adjacent in Haskell? It's five letters and starts with the letter P. I got no clue. I'm still trying to come up with another solution to this problem from before. Choosa, we'll play hangman. You've got, we're going to give you three lives.
我不知道。五个字母，以 P 开头。各位，我们来玩个游戏。在 C++ 的相邻变换（adjacent transform）和 Haskell 的 map adjacent 在 Q 语言中叫什么名字？它有五个字母，以字母 P 开头。我一点头绪也没有。我还在试图为之前那个问题想出另一种解决方案呢。来吧，我们来玩刽子手（hangman）游戏。你有——我们给你三次机会。
And, uh, if you guess, we'll give you five lives. Guess a letter. Uh, A. Incorrect. Down to four lives. Uh, D. Bryce guessed D, incorrect, down to three lives. Uh, E.
而且，如果你猜中了，我们给你五次机会。猜一个字母。呃，A。错误。还剩四次机会。呃，D。布赖斯猜了 D，错误，还剩三次机会。呃，E。
Bryce guessed E, incorrect, down to two lives. Uh, Y. I'm going to let you have another guess because that's a terrible guess, Bryce. Uh, I don't know. I don't know. I think you should just tell me. The Wheel of Fortune fans are very upset. I'll give you a letter. It's R. And that is P-R
布赖斯猜了 E，错误，还剩两次机会。呃，Y。我让你再猜一次，因为这是一个糟糕的猜测，布赖斯。呃，我不知道。我不知道。我觉得你还是直接告诉我吧。《幸运轮》的粉丝们很不高兴。我给你一个提示字母。它是 R。它是 P-R
blank blank R. This is the name of the adjacent transform algorithm, Bryce. Think about what... Prior? Woo! You got it correct, folks. The name of the adjacent transform algorithm is Prior.
空格空格 R。这就是相邻变换算法的名字，布赖斯。想想看……Prior？呜呼！你猜对了，各位。相邻变换算法的名字就是 Prior。
Note that in C++, our adjacent transform algorithm takes a template argument for the number of adjacent elements you want to look at, whereas Prior is fixed to two. There's no way to customize that, so it only looks at two elements at a time, similar to how adjacent difference works. And in Q, there are actually two specializations of prior because they're so frequently used, and those are deltas and differ. So deltas is basically prior with subtraction as the default binary operation, but it's commuted subtraction. So you're similar to how it works in adjacent difference. You're subtracting, if you're looking at sort of two elements at a time and you look at one on the left and one on the right, you're subtracting the one on the left from the one on the right.
请注意，在 C++ 中，我们的相邻变换算法接受一个模板参数，用于指定你想要查看的相邻元素的数量，而 Prior 是固定为 2 的。没有办法定制它，所以它一次只查看两个元素，这类似于 `adjacent_difference` 的工作方式。在 Q 语言中，其实有两个 Prior 的特化版本，因为它们太常用了，那就是 `deltas` 和 `differ`。所以 `deltas` 基本上就是以减法作为默认二元操作的 Prior，但它是经过调整的减法。所以，这类似于它在 `adjacent_difference` 中的工作方式：你正在做减法，如果你一次看两个元素，看左边的一个和右边的一个，你是用右边的元素减去左边的元素。
So if you have an increasing sequence of one, two, 3, 4, 5, you'll get back the values 1, 1, 1, 1, 1. Technically five ones because you copy the first value to be the first value of the output sequence, which I think is broken and we fixed in C++23. So that's deltas, which is basically the default behavior of adjacent difference if you don't specify a custom binary operation. And the second specialization of prior is differ, which is the prior or adjacent difference algorithm with the not equal to binary operation. So it's giving you a mask of basically where elements change. And this is a very useful algorithm because there's another function in Q called cut. And when you combine differ with algorithm because there's another function in Q called cut. And when you combine differ with cut,
所以，如果你有一个递增序列 1, 2, 3, 4, 5，你将得到的值会是 1, 1, 1, 1, 1。严格来说是五个 1，因为你把第一个值拷贝成了输出序列的第一个值，我认为这是有缺陷的，我们在 C++23 中修复了它。这就是 `deltas`，它基本上就是当你没有指定自定义二元操作时 `adjacent_difference` 的默认行为。Prior 的第二个特化版本是 `differ`，它本质上就是带有“不等于”二元操作的 Prior 或 `adjacent_difference` 算法。所以它给你提供了一个掩码（mask），基本上标明了元素发生变化的位置。这是一个非常实用的算法，因为 Q 语言中还有另一个函数叫作 `cut`。当你把 `differ` 与算法结合起来——因为 Q 中还有另一个函数叫作 `cut`。当你把 `differ` 与 `cut` 结合使用时，
you can basically get that chunking mechanism where it'll split your vector up into sublists and throw it in a table. We love that, folks. So I just, my whole little monologue here that I wanted to get on the pod, seeing as we got to find things technical to talk about while we're on the road in the Slovenia 2023 podcast is that adjacent transform it's just such a useful algorithm and it's such
你基本上就能获得那种分块机制，它会将你的向量（vector）拆分成子列表并扔进一个表格里。我们爱死这个了，各位。所以我的全部这段小独白——我之所以想在播客里讲这些，是因为既然我们在 2023 年斯洛文尼亚自驾游的路上不得不找点技术话题来聊聊——那就是相邻变换（adjacent transform）真的是一个非常实用的算法，而且
a shame that in C++ we called it adjacent difference because it completely obfuscates how useful and powerful it is and uh and yeah now you know we've got prior and Q two specializations deltas and differ we love it it. Over to you, Bryce. All right. I've been listening to you the last five minutes. I've been designing this algorithm in my head. You're the worst co-host, Bryce. Okay.
真是一件憾事，我们在 C++ 中把它叫作相邻差分（adjacent difference），因为这完全掩盖了它是多么的实用和强大；并且，是的，现在你们知道了，我们在 Q 里有 Prior 以及它的两个特化版本 `deltas` 和 `differ`，我们太喜欢了。交给你了，布赖斯。好的。我过去五分钟一直在听你讲。我一直在脑子里设计这个算法。你真是个最糟糕的联席主持，布赖斯。好吧。
So one of the key properties that you get with a scan is that… Can you hook me up with a cookie? I can hook you up with a scan is that... Can you hook me up with a cookie? I can hook you up with a cookie. One of the key properties you get with a scan... Do you want me to open it up or are you able to... Okay. One of the key properties you get with a scan is that every element of the output
所以你通过 scan（扫描）能得到的关键属性之一是……你能给我拿块曲奇饼干吗？我可以给你弄一个 scan 是……你能给我拿块曲奇饼干吗？我可以给你弄块曲奇饼干。你通过 scan 得到的关键属性之一是，输出的每一个元素
gets to include information from all of the preceding elements. So when I think about the output of a unique operation, I think that this is a property that you need, right? That if a unique operation is removing some elements, or another way to think about it is that it's sort of like shifting everything over. Like if you have two elements that are the same,
都包含了来自所有先前元素的信息。所以当我思考 `unique` 操作的输出时，我认为这是你所需要的一个属性，对吧？如果 `unique` 操作正在移除某些元素，或者换个角度来想，它有点像把所有东西都往左移。如果你有两个相同的元素，
you shift over the right element and then like you add an empty element at the end. And so figuring out how much you have to shift over like the last element is going to depend on how much prior elements were shifted over so you need some information from all prior operations so it seems to me like this is something that can be done with a scan and let's let's uh let's think about this as we would like a mathematical proof so let's start off with just the first two elements. So we have the first two elements.
你会把右边的元素移过来，然后就像在末尾添加一个空元素一样。所以弄清楚你必须把最后一个元素往左移多少，将取决于先前的元素被移位了多少，因此你需要来自所有先前操作的信息。所以在我看来，这似乎是可以通过 scan 来完成的。让我们——让我们像做一个数学证明那样来思考这个问题。所以我们先从头两个元素开始。我们有头两个元素。
We're going to look at those first two elements. And if they're equal, then, well, actually, the first two may be a little bit boring because the first element has no one that is, so like for the absolute first element in the sequence, you're always going to retain a unique because there's no element preceding it. But for the second element, you're going to look at the first element and the second element.
我们将查看这头两个元素。如果它们相等，那么——好吧，其实头两个元素可能有点无聊，因为第一个元素前面没有人，所以对于序列中的绝对第一个元素，你总是会保留一个 `unique`，因为没有前置元素。但对于第二个元素，你要查看第一个元素和第二个元素。
And if that second element is equal to the first one, then you need to omit it from the output. I guess, hmm... Can I ask a question? Yeah. What are you trying to do after the scan to get it in unique? Are you trying to store the index at which you need to copy this to afterwards? Are you trying to store a Boolean that says we don't need to keep this? Like, what are you trying to do with the scan?
如果第二个元素等于第一个，那么你需要把它从输出中省略。我猜，嗯……我可以问个问题吗？可以。在 scan 之后，你到底想做什么来得到 `unique` 的结果？你是想把随后你需要把它拷贝到的那个索引存起来吗？你是想存一个布尔值来说明“我们不需要保留这个”吗？你到底想用这个 scan 来干什么？
I'm trying to do the entire thing with the scan. There's no way you can. There's no way. Why not? Scan gives you N, like, you have N inputs, N outputs. That is, like, fundamentally in a separate category than unique.
我想用 scan 把整件事情全干了。你绝对做不到。没门。为什么不呢？Scan 给你的结果是 N 个输入，N 个输出。这在根本上和 `unique` 处于完全不同的类别。
Um, not if I propagate the information about, like, how many I've moved over to the left, and then, like, at the end, I just fill it in with, like, tombstone values. It's still not... It's still... You still can't do it. It's impossible. Like, because of the...
嗯，如果我把“我已经往左移动了多少个”的信息传播过去，然后——在最后，我只需要用诸如墓碑值（tombstone values）之类的内容把它填满呢？这仍然不行……这还是不行。你依然做不到。这是不可能的。因为……
Like, the semantics of the left to right, which is the associativeness of the scan operation, there's no way you can go backwards. When you get to the end of the array, there's a potential that you need to copy the very last value to be in the second spot. And there's no way to do that with a scan. Well, yeah, and so I was... Which is why I was asking, like, what are you doing after the scan? Because I'm not following what you're trying to build up to. Oh, so, so, okay.
从左到右的语义，也就是 scan 操作的结合律（associativeness），决定了你根本无法向后回溯。当你到达数组末尾时，完全有可能需要把最后一个值拷贝到第二个位置去。而这是无法用 scan 做到的。好吧，是的，所以我刚才——这就是我为什么问你“你在 scan 之后要做什么”的原因，因为我根本没听懂你想构建一个什么东西。哦，所以，所以——好吧。
So one thought that I had was that like some degree you may be right in that you may, you may need to do a scan over the reversed sequence. Um, because it may be the case that you don't need to know, um, like, like, like for the, to know what the value of that second element might be I need to know what the value is of all the rest of the sequence I think this is a fool's errand I don't think it's and also too
我当时的一个想法是，在某种程度上你可能是对的，你可能需要对反向序列执行一次 scan。嗯，因为情况可能是这样的：你不需要知道——比如，为了知道第二个元素的值可能是什么，我需要知道其余整个序列的值是什么。我觉得这完全是异想天开，这不可能。而且另外，
you're making the mistake although maybe this is just you're doing this as a mental exercise but unique I think that it is And also, too, you're making the mistake, although maybe this is just you're doing this as a mental exercise, but unique is... I think that it is... I simply think that it is incorrect that the only way to implement this in parallel requires ON temporary storage. I don't see any reason that you would need to do that. I think that you can simply chunk this up and propagate the information between the different chunks, and I don't think that you need to do two passes either.
你犯了一个错误——虽然也许你这只是在做思维体操，但 `unique` 我认为它是……而且另外，你犯了一个错误——虽然也许你这只是在做思维体操，但 `unique` 是……我单纯认为那种“在并行实现中唯有使用 $O(N)$ 临时存储才能完成”的观点是错误的。我看不到任何你需要这样做的理由。我认为你完全可以把数据分块，并在不同的块之间传播信息，而且我也不认为你需要做两次遍历。
Well, so we've talked about that solution. Yes, but yours required two passes still. But a scan inherently requires two passes anyways. But also, too, the thing I was going to say... Well, no, no, no. We now have a single pass scan implementation. Yeah, yeah. Anyways, I don't think scan is going to work.
好吧，我们讨论过那个解决方案了。是的，但你的方案仍然需要两次遍历。但 scan 本身无论如何就需要两次遍历。而且，我要说的是……呃，不，不，不。我们现在有了单次遍历的 scan 实现。行吧，行吧。不管怎样，我觉得 scan 行不通。
The thing that I was going to mention, though, is that unique is in the category of algorithms that, or category of problems where you only need a fixed amount of information to the left. You don't need the entire state up until then. And this is, we've talked about this, I don't know, three or four times, although people probably forget. And this is another reason why adjacent transform is such an important algorithm is that anytime you don't need the entire state that depends on everything up until this point
不过我要提到的一点是，`unique` 属于这样一类算法、或一类问题：你只需要左侧固定数量的信息。你不需要一直到那里的整个状态。我们已经讨论过这个了，我不知道，三四次了，尽管人们可能都忘了。这也是为什么相邻变换（adjacent transform）是如此重要的算法的另一个原因：每当你不需要依赖截至目前所有内容的整个状态、
and it's a fixed window, you don't want to reach for scan. You want to reach for a JSON transform. But why? It's not a fixed window here. It's just to the left. All you need to know is the value of the element to the left of the current element. And if it's the same, then that's when you don't have it. To make, yes, but really if you if
并且它是一个固定窗口（fixed window）时，你就不应该去求助于 scan。你应该去求助于相邻变换（adjacent transform）。但为什么呢？这里可不是什么固定窗口。它只是往左看。你唯一需要知道的就是当前元素左边那个元素的值。如果它们相同，那么这就是你不需要它的地方。为了做到——是的，但实际上如果你
the question that you're trying to figure out is where where do i put this value in like the output sequence like that requires more information you said that's not what you were doing though you said you were trying to implement this all in a single pass with a scan to do this in a single pass with a scan. To do this in a single pass, you need to figure that out. And then do something afterwards. Why? You're saying you need to figure out where it's going to go in the final sequence, but figuring out where it goes is not enough. You have to do something. You have to do something.
试图搞清楚的问题是“我把这个值放在输出序列的哪个位置”，那需要更多的信息。你刚才说过那不是你在做的事啊。你是说你正试图用一个 scan 在单次遍历中搞定这一切。要在单次遍历中完成这一切，你需要弄清楚这一点。然后在这之后做点什么。为什么？你说你需要弄清楚它在最终序列中会去到哪里，但仅仅弄清楚它去哪里是不够的。你还得做点什么。你必须做点什么。
Right, but if I figure out where it goes, then I can just put it there in the output. Let's just assume. It's going to require a full pass of the data in order to get that like you can't do it as you go like otherwise or if you do that essentially you've just implemented the sequential scan which is what the sequential scan does it basically has two iterators the one where you're copying to and the iterator pointing to the current element and it's just doing that comparison with the last element anytime uh they are not, you found a new value,
对，但如果我弄清楚了它要去哪里，那我直接把它放到输出的那个位置就行了。我们姑且假设。为了得到这个，它需要对数据进行完整的一次遍历——你没法边走边做，否则的话，如果你那样做，本质上你实现的就是顺序 scan，也就是顺序 scan 所做的事情：它基本上有两个迭代器，一个是你正在往里拷贝的目标迭代器，另一个是当前元素的迭代器，它只是在跟最后一个元素进行比较，每当它们不相等、
and then you copy it back, you increment the first iterator, and then you go on. But that's the sequential. Well, but we can assume random access iterators here, so we don't need to actually keep that stateful iterator. We can just keep an index into the iterator. An index is the exact same thing as an iterator for the purposes of copying to a certain place.
你发现了一个新值时，你把它拷贝回去，将第一个迭代器递增，然后继续。但那是顺序执行的。好吧，不过我们可以假设这里使用的是随机访问迭代器（random access iterators），所以我们实际上不需要保留那个有状态的迭代器。我们只需保留迭代器的一个索引。就拷贝到某个特定地方的目的而言，索引和迭代器完全是一回事。
But anyway, it sounds like you want a parallel version of that style of implementation. I have no idea how you would do that. I don't think it's possible. It may not be. It may not be. It just seems wrong to me that we would need temporary storage for this. Doesn't seem wrong to me, folks.
不管怎样，听起来你是想要那种实现风格的并行版本。我完全不知道你要怎么做到这一点。我觉得这不可能。也许吧。也许吧。在我看来，我们竟然需要为这个准备临时存储，这似乎很不合理。在我看来挺合理的，各位。
Let us know. Email us. We don't have an email. Let us know in the GitHub discussion at the top of the show notes. And, you know, maybe I've definitely been wrong before. Yeah. That's an interesting question. Interesting ad on the back of that truck.
让我们知道。给我们发邮件。我们没有邮箱。请在节目shownotes顶部的 GitHub 讨论区（GitHub discussion）里告诉我们。而且，你知道的，也许我以前确实也错得离谱。是的。这是一个有趣的问题。那个卡车后面贴的广告很有意思。
Oh, yeah. Yeah, there's been a lot of that. Would you like to describe the ad? Nope, I would not. All right. If you meet us at a conference and we're at some kind of social night and there are beverages involved feel free to ask us what was and that's that's how we'll know you're a real deep deep uh hard fan of adsp is that you're referencing you know episode 146 or whatever this is and you'll be like what was on the back of that uh italian uh
哦，对。对，这种广告挺多的。你想描述一下那个广告吗？不，我才不想呢。好吧。如果你在某个会议上遇到我们，而且我们在参加某种社交之夜，现场还有饮料的话，随时可以来问我们当时——这就是我们怎么认出你是一个真正的、深度硬核的 ADSP 粉丝：你会引用，你知道的，第 146 期或者诸如此类的节目，然后你会问：“那个意大利搬家卡车后面到底贴的是什么？”然后我们会告诉你。到那个时候我们也会有贴纸的，所以到时我们会顺便送你一张贴纸。好吧，我想我们要稍微暂停一下，主要是休息一下，因为我举着话筒的手开始酸了。
moving truck and uh and we'll let you know and by that point we'll have stickers too so uh we'll we'll give you a sticker while we're at it all right well i think we're gonna take a little bit of a pause mostly taking a break because my hand is getting tired from holding the microphone up. Oh, goodness, man. Next time, you got to do some work. You got to do some curls or something. Yeah. Here. You know what?
哦，天哪，老兄。下次你得干点活。你得去练练哑铃（curls）什么的。好吧。你知道吗？
You know what, folks? Bryce is tired. No, no, this is not a good way. What do you mean? I'm holding the mic now. And what are we talking about now? We're at episode 147. I think we should take a break anyways, because I'm
你知道吗，各位？布赖斯累了。不，不，这不是个好办法。你什么意思？我现在正拿着麦克风呢。我们现在在聊什么呢？我们已经到了第 147 期了。不管怎样，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为我
going to... I'm not going to be able to get this unique question off my mind. I need a few minutes to ruminate on it. Alright, folks. There's a chance. There's a chance this is the last time we record. And if it is the last time we record...
打算……我脑子里一直甩不掉这个 `unique` 问题。我需要几分钟时间来琢磨琢磨。好吧，各位。有可能。这有可能是我们最后一次录音。如果这真的是最后一次录音的话……
No, because we're going to record for tonight in Venice. Why? Because we've got to record at the end of the road trip. Yeah, like, what are we going to do, in our hotel room? Probably, yeah. That's so weird. We're definitely going to do it. Listen, folks, this is my goodbye.
不，因为我们今晚在威尼斯还要录音。为什么？因为我们得在自驾游结束时录音。对啊，不然我们要怎么办，在酒店房间里录吗？大概吧，对。这太诡异了。我们肯定会录的。听着各位，这是我的告别。
We're going to apparently record again, but my goodbye from the road of the Slovenia 2023 road trip. I honestly, I'm a little bit surprised that it even happened, because I'll be honest, it was a joke. I mean, we did title an episode, Ljubljana, here we come. But if you had actually asked me at the time, what are the odds that that's going to happen, I would have put it below 50%,
我们显然还要再次录音，但这是我从 2023 年斯洛文尼亚自驾游之路上发出的告别。说实话，我对它居然真的能成行感到有点意外，因为老实说，这之前就是个玩笑。我的意思是，我们确实给某一集起名叫过《卢布尔雅那，我们来啦》。但如果你当时真的问我，这事能成的几率有多大，我估计会把它定在 50% 以下，
because taking a podcast on the road is, you know, it's novel, especially in the tech space. We're breaking, you know, it's novel, especially in the tech space. We're breaking, you know, we're setting whole new standards. But we made it happen. The stars aligned. All right. Well, we're signing off for now. We will talk to you later.
因为把播客搬到路上来做是一件很新颖的事，特别是在科技领域。我们正在打破——你知道的，这很新颖，特别是在科技领域。我们正在打破——你知道的，我们在树立全新的标准。但我们把它变成了现实。群星闪耀，万物合拍。好吧。那么我们现在要结束录音了。我们过会儿再聊。
And spoiler, we do have at least two or three more episodes, which we recorded in Venice. So stay tuned next week to hear those. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the things we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a GitHub discussion
剧透一下，我们至少还有两三期节目是在威尼斯录制的。所以请锁定下周的节目收听。务必查看你的播客应用或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上的节目shownotes，里面有我们在今天节目中提到的一切事物的链接，还有一个 GitHub 讨论区，
where you can leave questions, comments, or thoughts. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline.
你可以在那里留下问题、评论或想法。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是“洒满信息 sprinkles 的混乱”。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。